today I learned that vitamins were
discovered by the butter industry it's
like 1913 and the margarine industry is
threatening to compete with butter
margarine being a fat substitute that's
not made from dairy anyway so these
massive Dairy Industries like in
Wisconsin are like no way Jose butter is
better than margarine we gotta prove it
so they do what corporations have always
done and continue to do which is hire
scientists to prove that their product
is actually really good and soon they're
showing that the rats that ate butter
were like better than the ones that ate
margarine and they were like oh this is
like a good marketing thing but like why
are the butter fed rats fatter and
happier and healthier and in doing all
their experiments they isolated this
micronutrient this molecule that our
bodies need they call it a vitamin and
because the one that they found in
butter was like the first one they
discovered they're like what should we
call it a like first letter of the
alphabet vitamin A that's how we got
vitamin A since then we've discovered 13
essential vitamins so you can think
butter for vitamins thank you butter
love you